les sports d'hiver ce n'est pas qu'à la
montagne la verrière une centaine de
jeunes découvrent plusieurs disciplines
sportives toutes liées à cette époque de
l'année j'aime bien pourquoi on s'amuse
comme mon pote on s'amuse tout s'est si
trop bien je trouve que la patinoire est
assez amusant mais c'est pas de la vraie
glace le hockey j'ai beaucoup a adoré et
le choeur lee hooker jr ou à la carline
j'aimerais voilà ça passe encore à
l'organisation du flep 78 fédération
sportive multisports curling patinage
escalade ou encore ok l'objectif faire
découvrir des sports originaux avec en
ligne de mire paris 2024 on a souhaité
rassembler sur un site
qui s'y prêtait celui de la rpd de la
verrière un ensemble d'activités qui
sont en phase avec les jeux olympiques
de pékin sur lequel on retrouvait à peu
près toutes les activités de montagne
qui s'adresse plus particulièrement un
public qui n'a peut-être pas la chance
de pouvoir en profiter seuls 10% des
français vont tous qui chaque année 40 %
ne sont même jamais allé ça permet de
découvrir des sports ça permet de
travailler la cohésion des équipes ça
permet pendant les vacances avec le
centre aéré de s'aérer la tête et de se
dépenser au plus près de chez soi donc
on a effectivement un partenariat qui
est gagnant gagnant autour des valeurs
du sport il est important de mutualiser
les moyens un petit peu pour pouvoir
aussi faire vivre je dirais les instants
éducatif que doivent avoir les enfants
les vacances apprenantes et plus on
s'associe ensemble et plus on développe
nos partenariats la ville s'est
rapproché essentiellement des centres de
loisirs structures de jeunesse et
certaines écoles le winter tour se
déroule jusqu'au 4 mars prochain
[Musique]